hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easyjet in dieser
woche sind wir frisch ganz frisch wieder
hier in berlin auf der straße und bei
uns ist luca die halle luca hallo
luca ist ein sehr bekannter polyglott
das kann man sagen und sein projekt
heißt seinem blog heißt der polyglott
dream luca wie viele sprachen spricht 13
ja verrückte sache wir haben heute schon
einige sprachen gehört von ihm und er
spricht wirklich alle sprachen fließend
das ist das krasse dabei welche sprache
sprichst du kannst du ganz schnell auf
zählen ja meine muttersprache
italienisch dann spreche ich auf
englisch französisch deutsch spanisch
holländisch schwedisch russisch
portugiesisch chinesisch oder chinesisch
chinesisch hat man eben zu deutschland
und japanisch polnisch und ich lerne
auch ungarn würde überhaupt nicht sagen
es sich fließen die sprache fließend
noch kann aber ich kann die sprache ich
kann es schon benutzen ein deutsches auf
jeden fall ziemlich gut und luca hat
einige methoden also seine spezialität
ist wirklich methoden zu entwickeln und
methoden auch zu testen und sparen zu
lernen und das werden wir jetzt die
uferstraße heute mal fragen wie lernen
menschen eine fremdsprache welche
methoden benutzen sie wieder los
sprechen sie andere sprachen lernt
französisch und englisch welchen
methoden haben sie das resultat
entschuldigung einfach meine französin
bis auch andere fremdsprachen ja halt
die klassischen immer in der schule
lernt englisch englisch französisch
gelernt und spanisch hast du vor auch
andere fremdsprachen zu lernen und es
ist schon genug
ich würde total gerne bks lernen aber
haben noch nie die zeit gefunden
wie lernt man am besten eine
fremdsprache in le pin ausland zu leben
also hier will ich mein deutsch
verbessern deswegen bin ich hier
dann kann man die umgangssprache lernen
und ja eigentlich immer so viele wörter
auswendig zu lernen wie man kann und
vielleicht irgendwelche sachen zum
beispiel fürs fenstern posten kleben was
fenster auf der sprache bedeutet titel
lernen möchtest du kabeln im alltag so
genau macht oder eine ganze wohnung ist
mit gelben post und falls du die zeit
findet würdest du in eine schule gehen
oder würdest du dir die sprache ganz
weit bei dir selbst beibringen
am liebsten würde ich ihnen ein land
gehen wo es diese sprache wo diese
sprache gesprochen wird weil ich glaube
dass es am einfachsten es im direkten
kontakt mit menschen im alltag sprachen
zu lernen
ich glaube die hauptsache ist dass man
motiviert ist das ist wichtig
ich glaube das allerwichtigste ist dass
man einfach spricht also ich glaube es
könnte sogar schneller gehen wenn man
einfach jetzt in irgendeinem land reiste
wo man überhaupt keine ahnung hat wie
die sprache funktioniert und einfach
dort mit leuten in kontakt tritt ist
geht wahrscheinlich schneller als man
sich zu hause mit dem vokabelheft
hinsetzt gut würde ich mal vermuten
erfahrungen bestätigen
german zu schaffen und luca zuvor los
gerät in chinesisch und koreanisch
spricht auch ein japanischer leider
nicht kann saudi alles nur eine
bestimmte methode die nur noch benutzt
oder gehst einfach nur zuhören und
sprechen zu hören und sprechen aber auch
die verben konjugieren richtig wie in
der schule ja ich bin du bist er ist ja
und dann alles was man lernt in den
alltag benutzen
luca du hast eben die leute gefragt ob
sie in eine schule gehen werden oder ob
sie daran glauben dass sie selber
sprachenlernen woran glaubst du denn
weil ich glaube dass die beste wahl
seine sprache zu lernen ist sich selbst
seine sprache beizubringen nicht legen
frage ich die ganze zeit ja du kannst
einfach jeden fall ja du kannst deine
schule gehen
aber ich glaube das ist auch das kann
auch schneller gehen
wenn du dir selbst die sprache beim
weißen eine schule ja ich war leider
weil ich eine schule allein um eine also
du meinst meine fremdsprache zu lernen
nein ich habe in der schule englisch und
latein gelernt und ja es war nicht so
dass es mich so begeistert hat
als ich nicht ich glaube dass so der
sprachunterricht in der schule schon
einfach ein bisschen falsch aufgebaut
ist oder schwierig zu machen ist weil
glaube ich das wichtigste ist die
sprache zu sprechen und vielleicht auch
einfach erfahrungen zu sammeln in dem
land also im land wohl die sprache die
muttersprache ist die sprache zu
sprechen
in kommunikation und nicht in sicht
nicht aus dem lehrbuch
du hast ja in 13 sprachen erfolgreich
selber gelernt jetzt reicht selbst an
zwölf zu erfährt viel weniger
da frage ich mich natürlich wie hast du
das gemacht und du hast ja auch selber
methoden entwickelt kannst du mal
irgendwie so ein beispiel sagen wie so
ein einbrecher insider tipp von luca
also das erste mal dass ich mir eine
andere sprache fremdsprache beigebracht
habe das war mit deutsch und ja ich
wusste nicht wie die grammatik zu lernen
und dann habe ich einfach gedacht okay
es muss eine methode geben und dann habe
ich diese methode gefunden das ist also
eine übersetzung also ich übersetze zum
beispiel um deutsch zu lernen
ich übersetzte texte aus dem deutschen
ins italienische und danach aus dem
italienische ins deutsche das hat mir
dabei geholfen die sprache zu entwickeln
das heißt nicht mit den leuten zu reden
sondern die strukturen der sprache zu
lernen zu erwerben und danach habe ich
natürlicherweise auch die shb im laufe
der zeit die sprache benutzt um mit den
leuten zu reden ich glaube die beste
methode um eine sprache zu lernen ist
leute mit leuten zu quatschen ja mit
leuten zu reden aber ja das klingt also
es ist einfach wenn man eine sprache
schon ein bisschen spricht also ich habe
eine freundin die lernt selbstständig so
koreanischen und chinesischen der schule
und koreaner springt sie sich noch
selber bei und ich meine sprachkurs bei
einer privatlehrerin und das ist
natürlich super also ich finde es schon
wichtig wenn man jemanden hat der
gesamtheit der muttersprache des landes
hat genauso beibringen kann
die man das auch wirklich nutzt die man
halt die sprache tatsächlich auch also
schwitzt und deutsch ist meine
muttersprache dass wir stellen dann
arabisch lernst du auch schon seit
oktober
warum es so einfach ist es einfach so
ist naja ich möchte halt ganz gerne
arabistik studieren und deswegen mache
ich das hast du vor andere fremdsprachen
zu lernen
vielleicht italiener ehrlich ich bin
italiener
du bist du bist schon zahlen gewesen
und du glaubst es in tallinn student
solltest du in eine schule gehen oder du
kannst hier einfach die sprache
beibringen beibringen du kannst es
einfach die sprache lernen ich glaube
wenn man dort lebt ist es leichter
einfach in italien zu wohnen wo würdest
du denn die tage wurden venedig winkel
statt
leute mit unserer episode heute mit luca
hier auf der straße in berlin
luca wer uns total gefreut ist dabei war
soll supercool und kommt zu dem wieder
nach berlin in 3 wochen cool damit sonst
rattert es hat uns auf jeden fall sehr
gefreut dich kennenzulernen
und wenn ihr auch zwölf sparen lernen
wollte ganz einfach wenn ihr auch mal
gucken wollt wie luca wirklich lernt
denn er dann guck dir einfach auf seinem
blog vorbei der polyglott stream dot com
und dort könnte vielleicht noch ein paar
tipps lernen wie man auch oder wie man
vielleicht zumindest eine sprache lernen
kann kann ja nicht jeder zu ersparen
danke schön locker dass du dabei weißt
danke fürs zuschauen und denkt dran wenn
ihr lust habt unser projekt zu
unterstützen wir finanzieren unser
projekt vor allem mit spenden dann guckt
man da vorne rein bei kathrin wir freuen
uns und sind natürlich zu the german
dann gibt es mehr easy german bis
nächste woche